bokassa 1er désavouer son ambassadeur à
paris confirme les mascottes et
démissionne les européens et nous une
série de reportages sur le mode de vie
de nos voisins ce soir le danemark
festival de cannes klaus kinski
candidats au prix d'interprétation
messieurs bonsoir c'était donc vrai il y
a bien eu massacre d'enfants le mois
dernier à bangui c'est un haut
personnage du régime centrafricain qui
tout à l'heure la confirmer dans une
conférence de presse assez pathétique
car on s'attendait bien au contraire à
de nouvelles dénégations des autorités
c'est donc l'ambassadeur de lempiras
paris sylvestre bangui 45 ans
représentant de son pays à paris depuis
quatre ans et proches de l'empereur qui
a tenu ces propos et spectaculairement
l'ambassadeur a donné sa démission et
demandé le droit d'asile à la france
nous allons l'entendre dans quelques
instants mais je vous préviens d'ores et
déjà que le réciter massacre dénoncé la
semaine dernière par amnesty
international et difficilement
soutenables à l'instant même où je vous
parle je rend effective
matt émission
d'autre part je demande instamment au
gouvernement centrafricain de me
destituer de mon grade de général de
corps d'armée quand l'armée nationale
dans l'armée impériale
messieurs les journalistes vous pouvez
intitulé votre article
j'accuse j'accuse le régime du monarque
centrafricain d'avoir fait assassiner
une centaine d'enfants entre le 18 et le
20 janvier est particulièrement dans la
nuit du 18 au 19 avril
j'accuse l'état centrafricain à travers
le régime de bmo d'avoir assassiné ses
propres enfants
compromettant ainsi l'avenir de notre
pays
il faut être sans coeur tour ordonné aux
soldats de tirer dans une foule
d'enfants marchand pacifiquement et
réclamant la paix rien que la paix la
scène du 18 au 19 avril a été
particulièrement atroces me révéler un
soldat de la garde impériale que je
connais très bien et qui a participé à
ce massacre d'enfants
ce soldat hamadi à la fin de
l'après-midi du 18 suivant l'ordre qui
nous était donnée nous ramassions les
collégiens dans les rues devant la
maison de leurs parents
quelquefois dans la maison de leurs
parents
nous les gestions brutalement dans les
camions militaires où ils étaient reçus
à coups de bâtons à coups de matraques
par d'autres soldats de la cour
impériale au cours du trajet qui nous
séparait de la prison centrale daraba
les enfants qui parlait un peu trop ou
qui criait nous les fusions terre avec
un pistolet placé à la tempe
la mort était instantanée
d'autres étaient morts asphyxiés dans
les cellules les cellules était petit on
y mettait 50 60 enfants
il n'y avait pas d'ouverture beaucoup
ont succombé l'ordre nous a été donné
dans la nuit d'enterrer les morts des
sacs nous ont été distribués et comme
les enfants à c était assez grand en se
contentant juste de cacher leur tête et
dans des fosses communes
après avoir fait chasser le gardien d'un
sim et hier nous les avons enterré nous
les avons j'étais sac par sac dans la
terre et nous avons mis la terre déçu
j'ajoute que le personnel de l'ambassade
à paris a refusé de se solidariser avec
son patron mes skis et plusieurs prenant
c'est que bokassa 1er n'a pas réagi avec
colère à écouter le répondent aux
questions que maurice werther lui a tout
à leur poser à kigali la démission de
l'ambassadeur baguette essai de plus pas
confiance et qu'elle est fier de votre
trahison non seulement vis-à-vis de ma
personne vis-à-vis de son propre pays
d'origine
vis-à-vis de la france parce que je ne
me suis pas permis de donner mais parce
que l'ambassadeur de la france je me
suis fait qu'il se donnait 1 grâce à
bassano et je dois reconnaître les
payant de qualité du jeu à bangui et en
tout état de cause je vous dis que
jamais en ce qui me concerne je ne
prendrai mes fonctions mais décision et
elle veut travailler ne veut pas fait ce
qu'il veut et de magazines politiques il
est tout à fait normal tout entière les
commentaires du fils de l'empereur
bokassa le prince george qui vit à paris
c'est la fin d'un empire le mieux pour
mon père s'il ne veut pas d'être tué et
qu'il se retire et le prince george ii
qualifié de courageuse la décision de
l'ambassadeur faut dire qu'il ya
quelques mois l'empereur bokassa avait
dit par téléphone à son fils réfugié à
paris qu'on lui ferai la peau
il est temps je crois de revenir sur
l'étrange personnalité de bokassa 1er
personnalités qui éclaire bien je crois
ce que je viens de vous raconter
voici l'homme que le monde entier
montrent aujourd'hui du doigt le
maréchal président a vu jean bédel
bokassa
le jour de son sac d'un empereur de
centrafrique
on lui remet ici manteau bordée
d'hermine cercle des pierres riz
couronne de diamants et 7 prend note
c'est l'apogée de son règne mais ce
couronnement marque aussi le début de sa
décadence
les cérémonies du sacre en coûter 20
milliards d'anciens francs 200 millions
de nouveaux francs ce sont les
centrafricains qui ont payé en grande
partie les fonctionnaires les employés
les commerçants tout le monde a dû
verser parfois plusieurs mois de salaire
pour le sacre de l'empereur bokassa
prenez
au soir du sacre déjà la colère gronde
mais bokassa 1er qui se vante d'avoir
servi 23 ans dans l'armée française
tient solidement les rênes du pouvoir
les acteurs de la révolte 0 % les moins
de 15 ans ces écoliers élevé dans le
culte de l'empereur jour laonnois donc à
sa premier décide qu'ils doivent porter
le tablier pour une famille
centrafricaine cela coûte parfois un
mois de salaire et à bangui on a
facilement 8 à 10 enfants
alors c'est la révolte ses enfants
l'armée et la garde impériale iront
parfois les chercher dans leurs maisons
pour les emmener en prison pendant les
émeutes de janvier et d'avril
aujourd'hui 140 de ses enfants manquent
à l'appel
l'empereur affirme l'udc se sont enfuis
et zaïre par simple peur d'être plus
larcher pas prête à présenter les
dernières nouvelles l'armée et la garde
impériale restent fidèles à l'empereur
merlet jours de son régime sont
peut-être comptés
oui d'autant qu aussitôt le sommet
franco africain du rwanda a décidé
d'envoyer une mission d'enquêté au
centre affecte mission composée de
représentants de cinq pays africains et
à l'instant le président la revue
française monsieur giscard d'estaing a
dit que la france tirera toutes les
conclusions que ce rapport appellerait
le monsieur giscard d'estaing de
qualifier les troubles survenus depuis
le début de l'année en empire
centrafricain d'événements très
préoccupante qui ont dit-il retenu notre
attention depuis leur origine
alors bien évidemment dans ces
conditions vous pensez que cette affaire
bokassa a largement dominé les travaux
de ce 6e franco africain qui vient donc
de s'achever à l'instant à kigali au
rwanda
tous les journalistes ronde été frappé
par la froideur dont la délégation
française a fait part à l'égard de vos
casas premier on a donc lu quelque peu
tendance à oublier le fond de la
conférence et pourtant le bilan est loin
d'être négligeable
c'est là en effet que le président
français exposés plus en détail dans une
salle apparemment conquise son projet de
concertation entre l'europe l'afrique et
les pays arabes
c'est ce que l'on pourrait appeler un
trilogue ces solidarités de la
géographie de l'histoire et de la
culture constitue une donnée de fait
pour l'europe pour l'afrique et pour
l'ensemble du monde arabe en outre quand
on étudie les rapports de ces trois
ensembles entre eux
on ne s'aperçoit qu'ils ont des liens
plus étroits et plus fort qu avec aucune
autre partie du monde
notre préoccupation est qu'il y ait une
prise de conscience de ces solidarités
qui deviendrait par voie de conséquence
plus affirmée et plus concrète car nous
vivons à une époque où de vastes
ensembles apparaissent et s'organisent à
l'échelle continentale
il est nécessaire pour l'équilibré le
mieux être du monde de demain que
l'ensemble des pays de l'europe
occidentale de l'afrique et du
proche-orient réfléchissent sur les
moyens d'associer plus étroitement leurs
destinées voilà il pourrait tout à fait
complet avec ses problèmes de l'afrique
noire sachez qu'une mission de
mercenaires à localiser un autre
maréchal idi amin dada il se serait
réfugié non pas en libye comme on le
croyait
mais dans le nord-ouest de son pays
l'ouganda les affaires françaises
maintenant à commencer par le dossier
énergie d'abord une proposition qui peut
faire du bruit une proposition du
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
jean-pierre soisson qui veut organiser
pour l'année prochaine une journée sans
auto une sorte de suite la journée de la
bicyclette qui s'est déroulée avant-hier
alors je ne sais pas comment les usagers
apprécieront mais toujours est il que ça
s'inscrit dans la ligne de la campagne
sur les économies d'énergie lancé hier
par le gouvernement
vous avez été nombreux à nous dire
pourquoi et seuls particuliers ce ne
sera qu'une goutte d'eau dans l'océan de
pétrole consommés par les usines c'est
vrai en partie aussi avons nous décidé
de vous montrer ce soir l'exemple d'une
entreprise qui a fait ce choix
d'économie et qui ne s'en mord pas les
doigts
bien au contraire
une seule usine peut économiser
l'équivalent de l'énergie domestique
consommée par une ville de 20 mille
habitants trois fois plus grande que
celle ci ce pari les tuileries de france
en charente l'on réalisé en quatre ans
pour elle il s'agissait d' économiser le
gaz de lacq utilisé pour cuire et séchez
les tuiles la rêverie
les économies d'énergie sont possibles
aux endroits où l'on consomme beaucoup
d'énergie
c'est à dire laisser choir et les fours
à raison d'environ un tiers pour le
séchage et deux tiers pour la cuisson
le schéma que vous avez ici représente
un four les wagons de tuiles qui sont
ces petits rectangles vont cheminer
progressivement tout le long du four
alors qu à contre courant circule une
masse d'air poussé par des ventilateurs
et qui vient de la gauche vers la droite
dans la zone de cuisson qui est alimenté
par le gaz on est à mille degrés
la masse d'air à 1000 degrés va
progressivement se refroidir au fur à
mesure qu'elles rencontrent les tuiles
au bout du compte si le four est bien
conçu ce qui est le cas on a une masse
d'air ici qui n'est pas trop chaude
il y en aura fait des économies
d'énergie malgré tout cette masse d'air
est encore à 100 degrés et nous avons
installé un échangeur de chaleur à ce
niveau qui permet de récupérer à peu
près 50% de ses calories qui s'est perdu
et on a donc de l'air à 50 55 degrés que
l'on peut envoyer vers les séchoirs où
l'on a également besoin d'air chaud pour
sécher les tuiles
avant il fallait mille permis pour
transformer une tonnes d'argile en
tuiles aujourd'hui il en faut six ans
seulement
l'économie d'énergie et de 40% mais
combien cela coûte-t-il à l'entreprise
apparemment très cher un cinquième de
l'investissement total
on pourrait penser comme beaucoup de
patrons que l'argent ainsi dépensé pèse
sur la compétitivité de l'usiné est bien
celle inverse qui s'est produit
car l'efficacité du système passé par un
empilage mécanique des tuiles sur les
wagons destinés au fonds une machine
avec un seul ouvrier aux commandes a
donc remplacé les huit hommes qui
empilait chacun 16 tonnes de piles par
jour la part de la main d'oeuvre dans le
prix d'une pluie il est alors passé de
50 à 24 % championne des économies
d'énergie les plus élevés de france le
sont aussi de la qualité du travail
elles ont été récompensées par le fonds
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
et ce n'est pas tout les économies
d'énergie sont devenus pour l une des
clés de la croissance
de modernisation de l'équipement
parallèlement aux économies d'énergie
clairement réalisée a permis de gagner
en productivité de façon assez
considérable ce qui nous a donc permis
également d'augmenter notre activité de
nous développer et contenu des
enseignements acquis dans l'usiné que
vous avez vu nous engageons actuellement
un nouveau programme qui prévoit environ
un investissement de 30 millions de
francs qui doit nous permettre dans les
dix mois qui viennent de pratiquement
doubler notre production
évidemment tout cela s'accompagne de
créations d'emplois qui ne sont pas du
tout incompatible avec avoir
d'hésitation galles au contraire à celle
ci s'accompagne d'un gain de
productivité significatifs
depuis cinq ans la tuilerie 325 salariés
au total
embauche 30 à 40 personnes chacun enfin
son chiffre d'affaires à quadruples et
et ses dirigeants envisagent maintenant
de partir à la conquête des marchés
étrangers avec peut-être l'implantation
d'une usine aux états unis mais problème
au phare bonal de france quelque 200
mineurs du bassin du centre midi en
occuper une partie de la journée le
conseil d'administration de la compagnie
à saint-etienne social toujours un éclat
des syndicats européens tout à l'heure à
bruxelles la délégation de la
confédération de ces syndicats a claqué
la porte du comité permanent de l'emploi
de la cee et ce pour protester contre le
refus des employeurs de parler d'une
réduction de la durée du travail dans la
communauté
voilà tout ça nous amène aux élections
européennes avec tout d'abord la remise
du prix europe ce matin à strasbourg à
raymond barre et un look spitz un prix
doté de huit cent mille francs c'est
alain poher le priant du sénat qui a
remis ce prix dont l'attribution est
contestée par le journal l'humanité qui
évoque le passé du généreux donateurs
dont on dit qu'il aurait eu quelques
faiblesses pour le régime nazi avant la
guerre les sud du dépôt de la liste jjss
ce n'est qu'un règlement de compte
personnel doublé d'un bluff publicitaire
a dit robert fabre c'est une deuxième
liste udf a dit jacques chirac entamé
cieux gens perdent trop tôt et michel
durafour du parti radical
il affirme que jean-jacques
servan-schreiber avait pris l'engagement
de notre candidat en aucun cas le bureau
national du parti radical est convoqué
pour demain réunion sans objet répond
jjss du côté des autres listes non
représentés à l'assemblée on dénonce
toujours l'inégalité de traitement
c'est le suffrage censitaire dit europe
écologie et région europe
c'est un cadre y participent
monopolistique ajoute pierre poujade
voilà au delà des déclarations des uns
et des autres il ya ce désir que nous
avons antennes de cécile clarifier le
débat et le choix des lecteurs voici
donc la suite de notre petit lexique
avec ce soir le conseil des ministres
les neuf
le conseil des ministres est l'organe de
décision de la communauté
c'est l'élément gouvernementale de la
cee il réunit les représentants des
gouvernements des neuf pays membres
chacun de ces pays y délègue un ministre
le ministre des affaires étrangères est
le principal représentant de son pays au
conseil mais selon les sujets traités
par exemple l'agriculture ou l'industrie
les ministres concernés participent
aussi aux réunions
la présidence est exercée à tour de rôle
par chaque pays membres pendant six mois
actuellement c'est la france qui assure
l'exercice de la présidence
le rôle du conseil repose sur une règle
fondamentale c'est lui qui prend toutes
les décisions importantes ou de portée
générale par exemple fixation des prix
agricoles ou établissements des droits
de douane en vérité le conseil et le
législateur de l'europe
en effet l'assemblée doit lui donner des
avis mais les ministres ne sont pas
tenus de les suivre
cependant toute décision sur laquelle le
conseil doit se prononcer doit être
auparavant étudiées et mises au point
par la commission qui est
l'administration du marché commun selon
l'importance des questions le conseil se
prononce à la majorité simple ou
qualifiée mais quand les intérêts
essentiels d'un pays sont en cause c'est
la règle de l'unanimité qui jouent et le
pays peut exercer un droit de veto il y
à plus de 60 session du conseil parents
et certaines durent des jours et des
nuits entières se sont ce qu'on appelle
les marathons européen
il ya les liquidations il ya aussi les
exemples de l'étranger les comparaisons
avec les autres pays membres de la
communauté
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous allons
entamer une série de reportages sur nos
voisins
aujourd'hui une première enquête sur le
danemark en france le travail des
enfants vous le savez est interdite
avant 16 ans alors bien sûr il ya des
exceptions les enfants peuvent
travailler à partir de 14 ans comme
apprenti ou dans des petits travaux
l'été ils peuvent aussi travailler pour
le spectacle mais vous savez que leur
salaire et dans ces cas-là consignes et
à la caisse des dépôts jusqu'à ce qu'ils
aient 16 ans et bien au danemark le
travail des écoliers chose courante
un travail qui n'a rien à voir avec ces
exploitations s'il 19e siècle et qui
leur permet non pas de soutenir leurs
parents ils n'ont pas besoin mais
d'avoir de l'argent de poche et si vous
demandez à leurs parents ce qu'ils en
pensent ils vous diront que cela vaut
mieux sûrement que de traîner dans les
rues
regardez ce reportage de laurence graff
à tous les mercredis ces deux écoliers
livres des journaux il reçoit à peu près
10 centimes ses livres dans un immeuble
et 15 centimes si livre le journal dans
une maison individuelle leur travail
fait l'objet d'une réglementation très
précise de 10 à 13 ans il peut faire des
travaux très léger pas plus de 20 heures
par semaine de 13 à 15 ans un maximum de
40 heures pas de travail dangereux et
des impôts au delà d'un certain salaire
si travail des enfants est si répandue
c'est sans doute parce qu'ils sortent
très tôt de l'école à deux heures et
puis c'est un moyen de se préparer à la
vie active tout en gagnant un argent qui
leur sert à s'acheter des biens de
consommation personnelle
faisait des traductions si je
travaillais dans un magasin de fruits et
puis dans un hôpital pourrait organiser
un ordinateur et vous travaillez
toujours non j'ai arrêté parce que
l'examen s'approchait que se prenait
trop de temps et vos camarades de classe
il travaille
oui le plupart des fenêtres ont tous
beaucoup de choses différence c'est à
dire que y'en a qui font des ménages ces
garçons comme des filles y en a qui font
des livraisons avec des voitures
différentes sortes de livraison et qui
travaillent dans des boutiques y en a
qui travaillent dans un maiden porno
mumbai il a 19 ans il fait que coller
une étiquette et bien combien à peu près
1000 1100 couronne par mois et qu'est ce
qu'il faut en se chargeant beaucoup de
choses différentes y en a qui utilisent
pour les vacances bien pour s'acheter
des 10 ou sortir et un aigle utilisent
pour un petit appartement
6 heures suit la législation et ça ne
porte pas préjudice à leur santé nous
pensons un général que c'est bien quand
puis-je les enfants de travail une deux
heures par jour mais seulement là les
travaux extrêmement léger d'ailleurs
c'est une tradition ici dans ce pays
et moi je les fais moi-même lorsque
j'allais à l'école c'est très courant
ici
dans la petite ville d'herstal au nord
de jute landes l'activité essentielle
c'est la pêche
aujourd'hui ça me dit pas d'école et les
enfants viennent aider les pêcheurs à
vider les poissons leur salaire ils nous
l'ont indiqué à peu près 60 francs de
l'heure de quoi s'offrir mes motos ou
épargner pour un bateau ça vous dérange
qu'on filme ses enfants ça m'ennuie avec
tout ce scandale qu'il y avait eu avec
les enfants des pêcheurs il vaudrait
mieux vendre les bois peint en train de
travailler
il ya un an et qui retrace le travail
des enfants avaient atteint de telles
proportions que les autorités se sont
tenues les instituteurs parce que les
écoliers dormait en place les
syndicalistes
parce qu'il risquait de se blesser et
aussi de prendre le travail des chômeurs
bref il ya eu une véritable polémique et
les enfants furieux jeter un jour un
syndicaliste dire stade dans une cuve à
poissons les organisations syndicales
ont récemment on a essayé de voir le
patron disais que c'était pas du travail
très grande travail mais nous avons
regardé comment c'était et avec les
écoles et serra directeur d'école disait
que les jeunes étaient quelquefois
fatiguée et s'était alors tout de suite
ça a été arrêté mais ça s'était produit
mais c'est un cas exceptionnel
c'est à la sauvette et à horaire réduit
que quelques écoliers dire stade
continue à vider les poissons sans doute
ont-ils une circonstance atténuante
la mer est depuis toujours leur horizon
est ce garçon de 15 ans comme ses
camarades nous dit mon avenir plus tard
c'est la pêche etc les poux sont l'une
des meilleures maternité parisienne
contaminé par un microbe inconnu un bébé
est mort il y a trois mois et 30 autres
enfants ont été gravement atteints
et alors pour isoler le germe
responsable une lutte énergique contre
l'infection a été entreprise est depuis
12 jours il faut dire qu'aucun autre cas
nouveau n'a été signalé faut dire aussi
que d'une façon générale la menace
intermittente de foyers d'infection
comme celui ci demeure la principale
préoccupation des maternités l'infection
des nouveau nés
c'est la plaie des maternités
elle peut se produire n'importe où
n'importe quand sans que l'on sache
lutter contre tous les germes qui
peuvent se présenter
l'infection c'est la première cause de
morts lors de la première semaine de la
vie il n'ya pas de l'année sans qu'un
établissement ou un autre n'est à
déplorer le handicap ou la mort d'un ou
plusieurs nouveaux nés contaminés soit
par leur mère avant au moment de
l'accouchement soit après la naissance
dans l'hôpital une maternité de lille
une autre de clermont ferrand ont connu
dans les années passées le décès de
plusieurs dizaines d'enfants avant que
l'on puisse identifier et éliminer très
difficilement les bactérie mortelle
et l'on se souvient que voici quatre ans
à paris la maternité port royal aussi
réputés que celle de baudelocque touché
aujourd'hui avait eu à déplorer trois
morts les causes sont multiples au
premier rang on peut retrouver bien sûr
le manque d'hygiène mais bien souvent et
malgré les infinies précautions du
personnel qui se lave les mains plus de
100 fois par jour les armes circulent
c'est pourquoi les responsables des
maternités met aussi en cause assure
occupation des lits et puis
l'humanisation de la naissance qui en
autorisant la présence du mari à
l'accouchement
le contact permanent de la mer avec son
enfant favorise cercle harmonie
psychologique mais hélas aussi la
prolifération des microbes dehors je
pense que le facteur essentiel et la sur
occupation des locaux qui est
effectivement un infecteur de gênes pour
toutes les mesures de désinfection et
d'hygiène d'une manière générale
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fermer la
maternité apprécions deux raisons la
première est que comme vous le savez
toutes les maternités parisienne sont
elles mêmes sur occuper la fermeture de
broadway qui aurait entraîné une sur
occupation supplémentaire et donc des
facteurs de risques supplémentaires à
d'autres maternités et puis d'autre part
et en accord avec la vie des hygiénistes
compétents nous avons pensé qu'il valait
mieux sur place étudiez réellement les
conditions de transmission de cette
infection de manière à pouvoir
efficacement lutter contre elle quelle
mesure vous prenez actuellement pour
nous en plus des mesures importantes en
accord avec l'administration de la
séance publique mesures sur les locaux
de désinfection de réfection de
modification de certains locaux et puis
des mesures personnelles visant à la
fois le personnel lui-même et par
exemple nous avons demandé aux familles
de ne plus apporter de fleurs et d'être
particulièrement vigilante quant à leur
contact avec les nouveaux nés dans le
service qu'en pensez vous
plus de danger nous avons non plus de
problèmes depuis maintenant douze jours
nous pensons que si deux semaines
s'écoulent sans nouveaux problèmes nous
pourrons être relativement réconforter
mais vous savez que dans ce domaine on
n'est jamais sûr de rien oui je précise
que sur les 30 bb atteint 5 seulement le
sens gravement
j'apprends à l'instant le début d'une
manifestation pour la libération des
inculpés du 23 mars et du 1er mai
manifestation qui regroupe surtout des
organisations d'extrême bourges grève de
solidarité des enseignants d'une école
toulonnaise un des instructeurs avaient
été la semaine dernière roué de coups
par le père d'un de ses élèves voilà
pour cette page cinéma qui s'annonce
maintenant nous repartons sur la
croisette à cannes
le héros de la chanson de roland
d'aguirre et de nocera tout cas hoskins
qui se présente aujourd'hui en
compétition comme un lauréat très
possible du prix d'interprétation dans
le rôle de wozzeck 1000 en scène par
werner herzog
il est bouleversant mais dit georges
bellour klaus kinski n'est pas un acteur
tout à fait comme les autres qui ne se
contente pas de jouer il devient
littéralement le personnage qu'il
interprète
si bien qu'il lui est difficile vous le
verrez de retrouver ensuite sa propre
identité
ainslie vos ex et la souffrance la folie
d'un homme qui vit avec la nature sa
propre nature et se heurtent à des murs
que ses coups de tête mais prendront
jamais je n'ai peut-être pas le plus
grand film de werner herzog mais c'est
sûrement la plus belle interprétation de
klaus kinski hertzog s'éprendre pas pour
une mettre en scène pour lui le mot met
en scène m mettre en scène une chose
manipuler dirigé l'acteur il refuse
il dit même si gaza côté a vaincu et du
super métro alors et en conséquence il
il approche avec tout ça fonctionnalités
aux approches à moins de me faire
comprendre qu'ils mettent à comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'on veut nous deux ensembles
et
rien vient de là tous vient d'ici il dit
pousse bien décidé mon âme de ma
souffrance de ces montants est depuis
toujours
j'en tirerai incarner complètement par
contre les coréens conscient ou
inconscient toujours parce que je crois
la call girl à la romieu parce que je
crois la création et rien qu'à man
permanent en conséquence je suis sa
gérante incarne c'est à dire celle
d'après je suis je suis complètement
j'étais aguirre je suis dégoûté boîtier
c'était nosferatu j'étais plus tous et
m'a jamais souvient une chose qui est
vraiment le plus commandé prononcé le
cul etc c'est gérer si vous voulez après
bob 7 10 mois jusqu'à deux mois
maintenant ça va du mois vous pouvez
plus décoller plus libéré des vols secs
chez des traumatisés vraiment traumatisé
j'ai eu la fièvre la nuit mais même
pendant le tournage pour le temps pour
le compte pas je pourrai me libérer
seulement parce que je commençais à
notre fille
distribution des prix après demain jeudi
le doigt des sports pour vous dire qu'en
cyclisme c'était la première étape de la
course du dauphiné libéré entre mâcon et
roanne la victoire est revenue au sprint
à l'allemand talent devant un trio de
français jacques esclassan régis ovion
et bernard hinault
tu as l'air endosse le maillot jaune que
portait au job de domec dernier long
week-end de mai celui de l'ascension à
titre d'exemple vous serez un peu plus
d'un million d'automobilistes a quitté
la région parisienne alors veuillez
écouter ses conseils si vous prenez la
route demain et éviter de l'apprendre
entre 15h et 21h la page de la météo
maintenant aujourd'hui tant qu'ap
essieux avec tantôt de belles éclaircies
tantôt des passages nuageux sauf sur le
midi où il a fait beau demain sera aussi
médiocre avec partout des nuages qui
donnant des averses
quelques éclaircies en cours de journée
dans l'ouest et une zone d' assez beau
temps dans le midi voilà votre dernier
rendez-vous avec l'actualité est avec
pierre-alain ce soir vers 23h30 point
final de la présente édition bonne
soirée à tous et à demain